we got one minute
kind of workout the safest place to put
this
you don't have the presentation here No
all right let's get this started
doors gonna shut excellent hi everyone
my name is MOC Mandal I am a developer
advocate for Google cloud platform and
I'm Gustavo ambrosio I'm the lead
developer for war dragons at Pocket gems
welcome to scaling mobile games to a
global audience using App Engine and
cloud datastore possibly the longest
title here at this event you could
probably also rename this as building
games without DevOps would probably be
quite appropriate as well so what are we
gonna talk about today well we're gonna
talk about a game called war dragons and
thanks Gustavo so much for coming by
today to talk to us about that we really
appreciate it so we're gonna go through
what that game is have a look at it it's
pretty awesome I like it a lot we're
gonna look at how its back-end
infrastructure works right so obviously
this is a cloud event we want to look at
back-end infrastructure we want to see
what what's going on there we're gonna
talk about what worked well what were
the success stories what were the great
things that happened we're also going to
look at some of the problems they faced
what lessons have been learned what can
we teach you about building back in
infrastructures for this sort of
application finally we'll put a bow on
it
gijin ice can reach a nice conclusion
and that will be the end of the session
sound good
sounds awesome excellent so let's get
started war dragons it's a great game
I've played it I really enjoy it Gustavo
do you want to tell us a little bit more
about what the games all about sure
thing
so war dragons is our highly polished 3d
real-time strategy mobile game where you
get to collect and control hundreds of
dragons to take out enemy bases in short
you get to control a lot of very awesome
looking dragons and blow up a lot of
stuff
it was Pocket gems first 3d game it was
our first game to have synchronous real
time multiplayer battles and our first
game to come out like on day one with a
lot of social features so features shell
such as gills multiple chat rooms
leaderboards Wars and much more so you
can see that in that respect was one
game that put a lot more pressure on our
servers than any other games that we had
before thanks for that so the first
question I have for you is like why did
you build a multiplayer game you could
have built a game that was just an
immoral device no interconnectivity but
you decided to build a game where people
could like battle each other and there
was a backhand and all that sort of
stuff what was the deal there so when we
started developing war dragons two years
ago we saw an opportunity to build
something that nobody has built before
on mobile so there were a lot of games
out there where you can battle other
people's bases but it was always
asynchronous like somebody can attack
your base but you cannot defend yourself
as they are attacking you there was
nothing like that on the market at that
point and we saw that opportunity and we
knew that we can build something like
that we also saw the opportunity to
build something in 3d which we also
never did before we saw that the market
was right and the devices was right for
that we're right for that at that moment
now hold on just a second is that you
think you over on the right-hand side
there oh yeah that third character thank
you for recognizing it thank you for
seeing the resemblance that Lord Gustav
that inspired by me obviously I think
you guys can see the resemblance if you
guys play war dragons you're going to
see Lord Gustav I'm the main villain of
the game obviously as well wonderful
ok so this game of yours seems to have
been reasonably popular yeah it's been
really popular this is a graph to
represent that so this is the number of
barrels per day that we had since we
launched so you see that first beginning
there is right before we launch when we
launch to get that big spike getting a
bunch of users after a few months we got
featured by Apple so we get that other
big spike over there that last spike
that came down was a special event that
we had we where people could battle and
limit a number of battles there were no
waiting time so people did a lot of
battles during that weekend and like the
interesting thing about this is that
with all those spikes with all that
variation we
have any meetings to say what's going to
be this impacts in our infrastructure
and how are we gonna handle millions of
users when we had none so far and our
server is going to explode and we're
gonna have to like run around like crazy
trying to fix our infrastructure we
never had any of that whenever we had
those spikes nobody had to like call
anybody else and and come fix our
servers because things are exploding we
never had any of that - all all those
things like our infrastructure just
worked throughout all this period of
time just so you guys have an idea this
is like war dragons been out for roughly
a year now and these number of battles
add up to 180 million direct battles
already so just so you have an idea of
the scale of it excellent okay so let's
talk a little bit about how it works
what's the backend infrastructure look
like and what's it powered by I know
when you and I first got together we
talked about how the primary part of the
back-end infrastructure is powered by
App Engine and datastore can you tell me
about the history there how you came to
use these two products the decision that
drove you did it do those things sure so
this decision was a little bit before my
time at Pocket gems but basically the
story is pocket gems started as you guys
had an idea for a mobile game and
started building that mobile game right
so there were two guys that knew how to
build mobile games but they didn't know
anything about server server
infrastructure even how to code for
servers and at some point they figured
like we need servers we need servers to
collect data from our users we need
servers to make our users do stuff
together so they figure that and they
started to look for a solution to their
problem right so they started
researching out there for a solution to
their problem and one of the things that
they bumped into was Google App Engine
there were the first few tutorials out
there for Google App Engine they started
to do the tutorials and try it out it
was free to try it out they were they
were also pretty much broke at that time
they were spending all their money in
marketing for for the game but Google
App Engine fitted that the requirement
was easy to use so they started building
with
right so it was kind of like a knee-jerk
reaction but throughout this six years
of pocket gems like we never had a doubt
that there was the right solution as I
said we never had trouble with like
servers exploding people running around
trying to fix because our users couldn't
play the game right we never had a
DevOps team like we don't have people
around like 24/7 because you know things
can explode and you have to get to the
office and and fix things so you it paid
off to us like we sometimes revisit the
decision to see if there's something
better out there but so far nothing
jumped out like it's been a good
solution for us when we started war
dragons we didn't even think about that
there was not an issue at that point so
it's kind of something you kind of fell
into but it's been so consistent and
easy to use that you just stayed with it
all the way through yeah it was the
right decision even though like it was a
knee-jerk reaction but it was the right
decision paid off excellent so just a
set like the stable set of contact so we
all have the same understanding hands up
the people here who have worked with
that engine or a familiar with it okay
about half the room how many people here
have used datastore or familiar with it
okay again about half the room great
that's perfect so I'm just going to go
through some very quick introductory
parts for these these products so that
we sort of have the same understanding
these products are what I like to refer
to as managed products what does that
necessarily mean though what it means
and I think to me and to many other
people is it's the very direct opposite
of this I know I've done this in the
past I'm sure many of you have to wait
you're like alright I think I'm gonna
get this much load in so I think I'll
need for web servers and maybe a
database replication and maybe some
other servers to do some other things
and this might be physical this might be
virtual but this is really kind of noir
fun all right you're managing your own
scale you're managing your own machines
it's not really great when we talk about
Google cloud platform services and
managed services what we really want to
be able to say is hey Google cloud
platform hey can you handle this for me
and it turns around this is don't worry
I've got this yeah we don't have to
worry about back-end infrastructure it
doesn't matter what our scale is it's
gonna handle that whole thing for us so
what does that actually look like
so app engine is one of Google cloud
platforms primary platform as-a-service
so what does that really mean
essentially what that really means is
you write your code it bundles it up for
you to deploy it and it pushes it up
into App Engine and App Engine handles
handles those requests right handles
taking that code running it in the cloud
for you so you don't have to worry about
it it's generally a web-based
application server system but it works
perfectly well for games like we were
looking at here
the big takeaway I want you to look at
here is that App Engine will Auto scale
for you so it doesn't matter how many
requests come in it'll spin up as many
instances of your code as it needed to
run it as much requests are coming in so
super super powerful at the same time
you don't have to worry about patches or
security or any of that sort of really
annoying stuff you just can rely on
Google services to do that on top of
that because it's a platform
as-a-service it comes with a whole bunch
of other services along with it we're
going to talk about two of those
services here that are used primarily in
in war dragons one is task queues task
queues is a service that comes with App
Engine to allow you to run background
processes it's pretty powerful it allows
you to back them up and queue them up
you can run them in parallel
it'll have retry mechanisms if those if
that code fails for any reason as well
as that we're looking at memcache which
I know you take great advantage of which
is a managed distributed cache system
it's if you've heard of memcache that's
been around for a really long time it's
pretty much exactly it's expected to be
and there's a variety of other services
too but we're not gonna worry about
those too much today on the other side
of things so rather than the request
side but on the data side we're gonna
talk about cloud datastore as well now
the great thing about plate cloud
datastore is it does sharding and
replication for you but it's an or
sequel manage datastore as well so it
doesn't matter how much data you put
inside cloud datastore you don't have to
worry about adding like replicas or
mirrors or anything like that and the
big takeaway here for this as well is
that it doesn't matter how much data
there is in datastore
you'll read and write x stay the same
which is really really really powerful
and so important for gameplay and making
sure your player experience is great
okay so we've talked about the products
great wonderful let's get into the
nitty-gritty and actually hear about how
all the things that power war dragons
work so when we got together we talked
about a variety of stuff we talked about
communication over rest we talked about
matchmaking we talked about leaderboards
you starve oh you want to take us
through some of those things sure okay
so let's start with rest in JSON so all
of our communication with Google App
Engine happens with using rest request
with the JSON as the data representation
over HTTP so this is like industry
standard works really well for mobile
because it's fast it's faster to to
render it's faster to to parse it's very
easy as I said industry standard so
google appengine handles that really
really well so that's why we chose to do
all of our communication we have some
real-time communication that we do over
a service called PubNub because
basically it was there was a service
that had that real-time so we didn't
want to rebuild that but all the rest of
the operations that happen in war
dragons all the reporting and all the
analytics that we have and all their
relationship between players all that
goes through GAE using rest and JSON all
over the HTTP that it's also a great
advantage because HTTP works everywhere
on mobile there's a lot of problems with
networks there's like crazy proxies out
there and you go to a coffee shop
there's another proxy and if you don't
use the HTTP we're going to have a lot
of problems on mobile if you use HTTP
with rest and JSON it's easy it works
everywhere so there's really like no
special sauce here there's nothing
particularly crazy going on it's just
basic rest yeah yeah the communication
is over basic rest and we can see oops
sorry no oops we can see here this is
again this is the number of requests
that we add right this is 24 hours when
we launch the game so you can see the
number of requests going up there a
number of errors don't go up like our
error numbers these are pretty low while
most zero over there and again we didn't
have to do anything we didn't have
like keep an eye out for our servers and
c4 we're gonna start to have much more
latency or anything like that it just
works whenever something like that grows
you can see the number of instances that
your game have it's being served by the
number of instances that Google spins up
for you they go up as well and your your
time remain constant so you didn't have
to like re architect your app as soon as
you got really popular or anything like
that it was all pretty much easy enough
to scale pretty much easy enough we had
some things that we're gonna see later
that we we faced but nothing that was
like user facing or that you know broke
the game in any way wonderful okay cool
so I know you do some particular
interesting things with App Engine and
versions for those of you who aren't
aware one of the nice things about App
Engine because it's platform
as-a-service
we take your code when you deploy it and
we actually deploy it as a version up
into the cloud this actually normally
ties directly to a unique URL as well
this is nice for like testing if you're
doing say smoke testing but in a web
application context normally you just
send it all to a default version which
becomes like your canonical or your
production version but I know Gustavo
you do actually something really
interesting here can you explain that
yeah so we do something different with
versions so versions is something that
usually people use for testing so if
you're doing a new feature or if you're
changing your website you spin up a
different version and you test on that
version and your production app is still
the same if you have multiple developers
working every developer can have their
own version so nobody's stepping on
anybody's toes but one of the uses that
we got from versions which is a little
bit different is to so that we are able
to break compatibility between our
client-side code and our server-side
code so how do we do that so let's say
in this example here I have my client
version 2.0 7 deployed and people are
using that dead version and so for that
version we deploy a version of Google
App Engine that is compatible with that
so the Google App Engine version 2.0
seven as soon as we submit another
version of the client code that breaks
compatibility
what we do is we deploy another version
of Google App Engine that is compatible
now with that version and because the
clients they have different URLs they
each communicate with their own versions
so for a brief period of time whenever
we release a new version we do have
clients playing in two versions of the
game so if we had only one server out
there we would break every one we will
need to have crazy code that handle like
if it's this version do this if it's
this version do that and we all know how
ugly that can be with this scheme that
we use we don't have to worry about that
we can just break that compatibility
right out and it all works so then we
have those two versions as people are
upgrading at some point we force people
to upgrade and then what we do is we
basically just take down that 207
version of the game as we do that that
URL doesn't see that version so Google
just redirects you to the default
version and the default version is
always the new one and then now all that
the client is going to get is that
please upgrade your game is not
compatible anymore you need a new
version but by that time they everybody
can upgrade and then everybody goes to
the to version 2 point I'm great so I
know matchmaking is an interesting
problem so if you aren't familiar with
games I'm sure many of you are
matchmaking is basically just trying to
take two players from a pool and pair
them together so they can have a game
together I know it's an interesting
problem because you don't want like
drastically outmatched players you don't
want someone to be come in and be like
completely dominated or to completely
dominate another player you want it to
be such that they're at almost similar
power levels so it's very close and then
they have a really interesting game that
way how do you solve that problem so for
Ward dragons we have millions of players
and every player is going to have a
different level right if you just
started right now you only have a few
dragons your base has only a few a few
buildings but if you've been playing for
years as some of our players have like
you have a full base you have a lot of
dragons that a lot of very strong
dragons that you can battle so you don't
want those two people battling together
because one is just going to crush the
other and the other is not going to win
battle right so you don't want that to
happen he's gonna frustrate your users
so what we do is we create basically
buckets of users oops sorry
we create buckets of users with their
power level basically so we calculate
your power we put people that have that
relative power with the same bucket and
whenever we need to fetch an opponent
whenever a client goes say hey I want to
battle someone we can quickly see what
is your bucket we go to that bucket and
data store we fetch any of the opponents
that are there we have all the data that
we need is in that bucket in the data
store and we serve that to the client so
it's a really efficient way to have
people battling people that have their
their their same power level without
having to like do big queries in a data
store to search for people so we already
do that we do that in an asynchronous
way so it doesn't take any time for the
users so whenever let's say a user does
a battle or up create a building or or
get an you get a new dragon what we do
is we add a task to our task queues and
that task queue is gonna see okay what
is your power level now right and see if
it has to change your bucket so if it
decides that it has to change your
bucket it seemed please take you out of
one bucket put you in another bucket and
now when you battle for the next time it
simply picks you out out of your next
bucket so really simple solutions just
something that would be really really
complex in a normal database system
right so using a datastore and task
queues this became really simple for us
very easy and fast for therefore the end
user as well cool so I know you also do
special events on occasion within your
world I know you do a conquer the world
map where you have guilds of players to
fight against each other tell us about
what happens there I know you have to
render a world map so all the people in
the game can see what's going on what
sort of problems you're solving there
sure
so conquer the world was an event that
we had for a weekend
where
our guilds which are groups of players
that Bend together to serve as allies
the guilds would start every one with
their own territory in a map such as
this and throughout the weekend you
would battle your your opponents and
gain or or lose territory and so the
goal what you have as many times much
territory as you have this is what
happened during that weekend so you can
see all the players all the guilds
expanding and contracting like there was
a lot of strategy involved there
people were like trying to save their
dragons to the end so they can conquer
more so you see the green team and the
yellow team I see the orange teams in
spewing very very orange team eeeh and
the green team that was the the final
result of of that of that weekend for
one of our divisions right so what we
wanted is we didn't want just you have
something where you know what number you
pair like how many square feet you you
have or territory you want users to have
a map to have that sense that they are
attacking and gaining territory so
you're doing that on the client side
would be extremely difficult for us so
we decided to do that on the server side
so on the server side what happened was
we have task queues going in
periodically we're doing that every five
minutes so every five minutes those task
queues would grab every data from every
battle that everybody fought during
those five minutes recalculate
territories and actually generate that
image so this for every division
division is a collection of guilds which
is kind of like matchmaking for gilts
for that level of guilt right so you can
see there we have those those skills
which are actual real names of guilds
that we had off divisions that we have
and every test you is calculating that
one of the things that we did here which
is a little bit different than than what
task queues do test queues whenever you
add something to a task you if you add a
hundred thing to a task you Google App
Engine is going to try to run that as
fast as possible right so if if you have
a hundred if you have like two servers
is going to try to spin a bunch of
servers execute that when you don't
have anything it takes down your server
so this will be something what you would
see if we had that that are those tasks
use running with what is called a
default scaling so every five minutes
you would see a spike in the number of
servers that Google spinning up for you
then it spins down you go almost to zero
and then five minutes later you're
spinning up a bunch of things right so
this is very inefficient from a
computing standpoint and from a cost
perspective queue so for this case
because we knew the number of divisions
that we had like the number of division
doesn't change during weekend we changed
that on a periodic basis but we know
it's not going to change during the
event right and we know we want to
render that every five minutes and we
know rendering takes the next amount of
seconds what we do is we use basic
scaling so basic scaling basic you you
say don't spend more than X number of
servers for me so when you do that then
you see something more like that so you
still add a hundred 200 tests in your
test queue but Google's not gonna spin
up more servers it's my spin up one
maybe not but you're gonna see something
way more constant which is great for
your for your cost and it's also great
for for your computing because you know
computers don't have to start and stop
all the time so this is one of the
things that we did differently than you
know the default scaling that that
everybody uses out there so this is
really cool because you knew exactly how
many divisions you had and you knew that
wasn't gonna change you're able to take
advantage of that to get more efficiency
out of your system yeah whenever you
have that fixed computing power that you
know that's what you need using basic is
a it's a better it's a better use of
your of your computing power cool like a
Ford I believe you also use memcache and
some other things as well in that aspect
so yeah that was or some other
improvements that we did to conquer the
world map using some of the Google App
Engine features so we use memcache to
cache the metadata so we had some
metadata like for example where's your
capital so the client would render the
name of the guild inside of the map so
we had to have where's that gonna be
rendered on the client side so we had
some metadata
and we had memcached you to cash that
because it's really fast for the client
to to grab that information we also use
something called Google edge cache which
it's a basically a caching of your
information so whenever we generate that
image Google asks us for that that image
we say this image can be cached for five
minutes so then we don't use that
computing power anymore Google edge
cache just takes care it knows that that
image can be started for five minutes
and it just serves that so it's
something that also saves us money and
makes it way faster for the client to
get that image because you don't have to
hit a computer to grab that image and
return that for you returns from from
edge cache almost immediately
excellent so I know you also have a
leaderboard system so players can rank
themselves or be ranked within a whole
subset of all the players I know that's
kind of an interesting problem you want
to sort of describe the problem so yeah
leaderboards are an interesting problem
they they seem simple in the beginning
but then you start to see that there's a
it's more complicated and it seems so
leaderboards they basically need to
answer those three questions for you in
a very efficient way right so when the
leaderboard I need to know what is my
position in a leaderboard needs to
answer that fast then it needs to answer
what are the people that are around me
so I can see like people that I want to
attack later so I can jump up on their
on the leaderboards and it also needs to
answer like who are the people there are
in position 100 to 120 if our users are
paginating or their if they're scrolling
you need to grab more data you need to
be able to grab positions 100 to 120
really fast right so it seems easy right
but as you're gonna guys are gonna see
databases are not really suited to
answer those questions so let's see
let's see a little bit why right so this
is an example it was actually this was
one of the leaderboards that we have a
few days ago that I grabbed so let's say
that you have this database you say ok
that's easy I'm just gonna create a
database with player name and score I
create in this indices for the player
name and the score so it's easy for me
to say okay I want to see the Messi or I
don't know how that's pronounced I don't
know why I chose that name there
better names for me to choose but well
okay so that messy guy there you want to
know what position it's easy for you to
check messy but it's not easy to know
the position right because databases
they basically have to count everybody
that comes before that person to know
the position there's no position there
so then you say easy just add a position
there why not
right so you add up a column for
position and now you know Oh Massey is
number nine easy problem solved not so
much because what happens when massive
wins a battle and jumps up on the
leaderboard now you have this weird
thing here where mass is actually number
four but the position says number nine
because the whole record moves up right
you can't move partially so now you have
to you know you imagine already what you
have to do here you have to go and
change a bunch of those records you have
to change all the records between four
and and nine there right and that's a
very costly thing that you're changing a
bunch of records that potentially other
people are changing so it's not an easy
problem it's not as easy as as it looks
so when we started building war dragons
we started looking for solutions we're
like okay people had that problem before
games have been out there competitions
have been out there people had that
problem before and lo and behold we
found some project that Google did for
Google Code Jam because Google code jams
the competition of code they had a
leaderboard of sorts so and they
released that project as as open source
for Google App Engine because that's how
they run Google Code Jam of course so
mark why don't you explain to us how how
that solve our problem
certainly so I had a look at this code
and I'm gonna explain it fairly simply
there's a link through the blog post
which has a link to the code so if you
want to go deeper into it you're more
than happy to essentially what it does
is it uses datastore to build a data
structure inside it that's able to
answer these sort of leaderboard
questions very simply what it actually
builds is a tree so the first thing you
do when using this code is you select
your range of what your score could be
here I've selected an arbitrary range of
0 to 10,000 as that's what my score is
going to land into then we untied that
tree we're gonna pick essentially an
arbitrary number
nodes underneath it here we're gonna
just use three for simplicity and we're
gonna split up those ranges into each of
those thirds so you can see easier like
3000 3000 to 6000 so on and so forth and
then so on and so forth and down the
tree as we go and that's great and then
what happens is when we have a score
come in so if someone gets their score
set it goes in the tree in that range
that they fit that's cool but what we
actually do at each node is we count up
how many scores we have for each of the
children in a parent node so if we had a
hundred scores it would look something
like this at the top we have 50 25 25
we continue down the left we would add
up all of those two then 50 so 10 25 15
so on and so forth down the tree this is
actually really powerful for
leaderboards if we want to ask questions
like hey how many scores do I have in
total all I need to do is count up the
number of children that I would have in
the top node and that would be a hundred
if I want to do something like hey I
want to go find the top 10 scores all I
need to do is go down the left side of
my tree until I've counted up till I
have ten results if I had a score that
was 2222 and I wanted to know what
position that was I could just count to
the left of that tree and potentially
outboard depending on my position as
well so I can answer these sort of
questions really easily using this data
structure but like I said the notes for
this and the URL for this are all at the
very end of the talk so if you want to
dig into it further this is a very
simple explanation of how it works but
it does solve this sort of problem and I
believe it also so sorry I believe also
App Engine for you you use it
development using a whole bunch of other
ways you love it that much tell us about
that
so yeah so one of the things that we do
that is the classic way of using
versioning we use versioning a lot to
develop new features so whenever a
developer needs to develop something
else we every developer have their own
version of the server running out there
it's really easy to deploy there's a
desktop app press a button it deploys
that for you and then you can test your
features there and whenever that feature
is properly approved you can then put it
on master and then we have a process
that deploys that to our production
servers all the time so every developer
has their
nobody steps on anybody's toes classical
use of that we do that all the time
another thing that we do a lot is we
like je so much and it's so easy to
develop for that that we do our own
internal tools for that we go using
Google App Engine so at some point were
dragons grew a lot it was our largest
team to date we have like more engineers
than any other team at pocket gem had
before so we needed to step up our game
in code reviews and and making sure that
our quality of code was good and we
didn't have any tools out there that
would serve us the way we want at you so
we just rolled our own like one of our
developers work for a little bit less
than week wrote a code review portal for
us then now we use all the time the
whole company now uses that code that
code review portal I we started adding a
lot of process and we all know the
developers hate process so what I did
was I build a robot using Google App
Engine just goes and does the process
for us we don't have to care about that
we just do a few things on github around
on our ticketing system and the robot
does all the process things for us so I
just wrote that in a few days
rolled up a new server is there we have
a new server running really really easy
we use that all the time for our for our
development tools as well
excellent so you love it so much for
building your Production apps you use it
internally as well I even have some of
my own like I like it so much that I
start I cannot act on extinct and I
needed a server to serve information
like oh I'll just do it in Google App
Engine it's it's free for very small use
so I just rolled my own and and deploy
there on my personal account cool okay
so it can't all be sugar and spice there
had to been some challenges some
problems we should probably have a look
at those and see possibly what dragons
you had to slay terrible joke let's have
a look at some of that and so people
here can learn from the lessons that you
learn while you're building war dragons
sure so one of the problems that we
faced is that were dragons generate a
lot of what we call events so events are
various things that happen inside the
game that we can be interested in you
know how people are using the game
what time of the day people play more so
there are a lot of things that happen in
the game that we save as events and then
we send that to our server so we can
analyze that data later but as you can
imagine we have like millions and
millions of lines of events coming in
all the time from our users and the way
that data the data store costs are made
they are you are charged by operations
in your data store so if you're saving
one event in your data store that is one
operation if you're saving a hundred
events in the same table in the data
store that is also one event right so we
need to figure out a way that we could
save money on that like instead of like
getting information from a syrup from a
user we have a hundred events there and
doing a hundred operations because they
all go to different tables we needed to
figure out a way to do that q I'm sorry
mark but to reduce a little bit of our
cost so let me tell you how we did that
using Gies own infrastructure so what we
did was we use memcache for this because
memcache is really well-suited for this
problem it's very fast so what we did
was basically we create a bunch of
records in in our memcache that receive
the events from from the players so
those these particular records in the
data store they just accumulate a bunch
of events of different types they don't
care they just start you get that
information there at some point memcache
has a size limit so at some point to
reach that limit when we reach that
limit what we do is we fire up a test
queue that test queue now grabs all the
events from that particular record that
is being that is full and it starts to
sort into a second level of records in
memcache which are in this case
particular to every event so if your
event type a goes to that record if it's
an event IB goes to their record and so
on and so forth and when that the record
is emptied it can be reused by other
clients at the same at the same time
those other second-level records are
also going to become full when they
become full we fire off an
their task in the task queue and now
they put that into the data store so now
we turn what could be hundreds thousands
of events there could be thousands of
operations now they do only one
operation because now they're sorted by
by their table and they go straight to
that table and then they can be reused
for for another for another operation
but with that like we were able to
reduce millions and millions of
operations to few operations per per
minute excellent so you're able to use
memcache to to really make that an
efficient and faster process and as
we've seen before you're using memcache
all over the place as well yeah
great so one other issue I know you
faced is datastore data contention
issues for those aren't familiar one of
the one of the issues with datastore or
possibly one of the challenges with the
datastore is there are some hard limits
around how fast you can write or change
data on a single entity so if you have
two processes operating on a single
entity within datastore at a given point
in time it can turn around to be like
whoa slow down
I'd like you to like stop repeating me
so fast I know that was a problem for
you you want to talk about that and how
you ended up solving it so yeah data
contention was a problem for us so you
can imagine that we have some operations
that touch a lot of things so I'm going
to give the example of battle reports so
whenever you finish off a battle you
send that battle report to our servers
and our servers need to do a lot of
stuff so it needs to award the loot that
you got from from that from that battle
at the same time these to remove results
from your resources from your opponents
record in each towards you metal so you
can go up on the leaderboards
so all that touches one record such as
two records actually in the players you
have to actually add to the world
results if that battle is part of a war
you have to go and add the war results
you have to change your leaderboards you
have to change your matchmaking bucket
and then after you did all that
now you respond to the search user user
so we have one problem it is like
there's a lot of time that the user is
not getting a response and maybe your
game is waiting on a waiting screen so
that's not good user experience and the
other problem is that with this you
imagine with millions of users doing
that a lot of them might be hitting the
same
record so am i if two people from the
same guild are doing a battery in a war
they all gonna hit the same war record
right and when that happens you get data
contention one one client is to wait for
the other one to finish and if they have
if they're way too long
this operation is gonna fail completely
right so not not a good solution so what
we did was again using all the resources
for Google App Engine we broke that down
so what we did was we do the least
amount of possible work that we need to
give a response to the user so the user
at this point only needs to know how
much loot it got from from that battle
that's it so we do that and then we add
a task you what's called a transactional
task it's kind of a test queue but has
special properties which is really nice
we at that point can the order just goes
to one record over there then we return
to the user so really fast and then we
add a task to the to the task queue that
task is going to do all those things
that we were doing before so still gonna
remove resources it's still gonna give
you medals it's still gonna add to the
war results you're gonna change
leaderboards you're gonna change your
matchmaking bucket all of that and then
you're gonna ask but can't that run into
data contention as well you're doing a
lot of stuff into into one operation and
yes you are right thank you you're very
smart audience here so that happens but
when that happens it's an awesome
feature of task queues is that they just
retry so if there's any data contention
there and your operation fails it just
goes back to the queue and after a while
it just retries so when it retries at
some point is not gonna face data
contention and at some point it will
commit all that takes a while but it
doesn't change the experience in any way
for our players those operations don't
change anything in a meaningful way for
our players so they can be done
asynchronously they can take awhile they
can be retried so that's a really really
nice feature of task queues excellent so
you're able to take advantage of the
fact that you have a lot of control over
how ice cues can retry exponential back
a number of retries number of days
center etc and so you can make sure that
this always happens that just a question
of how long s queues are awesome like if
you have a bug in your code you can just
change that code and redeploy all your
operations that failed rerun on that new
code so you can fix code on the fly and
you can see the size of your queues it's
amazing it's really awesome we have some
cues from our old games they're just a
fun fact we have tasks there have been
running for two or three years because
we have buggy code there and because
it's it's an old game we don't care we
just let those things run there and
they've been running for like three four
years we have old tests like that it's
relentless fine cool all right so I'm
sure your code is perfect mine often has
some issues
I know App Engine gives you log
aggregation by default but how do you
use that I know you've got some nice
ways that you use that within add more
dragons yeah so the log aggregation that
we get out of the box it's really useful
it's really easy to use so this is just
the default console log that you can you
can access for Google App Engine and you
have a search box over there at the top
that you can just search for anything in
your request or in your headers so in
our case for example we use that a lot
to track down problems that users are
having every user has a unique ID which
is a hash like ID that is really easy to
search for because there's no you're
never gonna find another one in your
request so whenever we need to know what
requests are failing for a certain user
we just go there we search for their
their ID it comes up with all the other
other results and then we can dig in we
can go in and see the metadata the proto
payload we can see all the the get
requests parameters we can also see we
can you can add logging statements to
your code and they will also appear here
as the logging statements if there was
an exception in your code you're going
to see that exception so it's really
really easy to use tool that we used all
the time that is right out of the box we
don't have to we didn't have to do
anything to get this one alright great
so we've been talking today about
running games at scale but really what
we're talking about here is running
games at scale without having to manage
your
back end we've looked at two special
products here App Engine for scaling our
requests and order scaling those
responses and also we've been looking at
datastore we're looking at managing our
scale of data using datastore but please
remember these are just two products
that exists within Google cloud platform
that can help you build games we
certainly have a huge loop of products
that will help you build games as well
as a variety of other applications we
definitely have a huge number of other
sessions still here at JCP next so if
this stuff is interesting to you please
make sure you check out all of them
finally I'd like to say thank you very
much to you Gustavo I appreciate you
coming thanks for having me if people
want to learn more about war dragons or
pocket gems I know you're coming out
with a new version soon where can they
go oh yeah I forgot to ask one thing
like who here has played war dragons
before alright so we have some people so
hopefully that's gonna change right now
so if you guys want to play war dragons
you can just go to war dragons calm
awesome website there's a lot of
resources out there if you want to learn
more about pocket gems just go to pocket
gems calm if you're an engineer or a
product manager or a game designer or an
artist come talk to me go to our website
we are hiring so come talk to me I'll
hang out a little bit more outside
excellent and if you're interested in
App Engine or data store the URLs are up
there along with the link to the global
game the global game jam or Google Code
Jam code that is there in the URL right
there and thank you very much to you all
for listening to us we really appreciate
it thank you so much
you